nouvelle conférence de presse autour de
la propagation du coronavirus hier soir
pendant une dizaine de minutes le
directeur général de la santé a dévoilé
les nouveaux chiffres avec pour
conclusion une augmentation des cas et
des décès dans l'hexagone
jérôme salomon a tenté également de
rassurer notamment sur le passage d'un
stade épidémique à un autre le passage
d'un stade à l'autre implique tout
simplement une gradation mais surtout
une continuité dans la réponse dans la
prise en charge entre les mesures prises
au début d'une épidémie les mesures et
les mesures prises à la fin ainsi nous
avons débuté vous le savez par le stade
1 pour lutter contre l'introduction dû
virus nous sommes actuellement au stade
2 pour freiner la diffusion du virus
nous évoluerons va le stade iii de façon
progressive
probablement inéluctable ou
difficilement évitable puis nous
terminerons avec le stade 4
correspondant à un retour à la normale
est donc l'objectif
l'objectif très clair des autorités
sanitaires c'est apporter des réponses
adaptées cohérente et proportionnée
selon la situation épidémiologique ce
vendredi le premier ministre annonçait
pour sa part des mesures concernant les
deux départements les plus touchés sur
le territoire le val d'oise et le haut
rhin nous annonçons ce soir un
renforcement des mesures qui limitent
les contacts la fermeture à compter de
lundi matin et pour 15 jours des crèches
maternelles collèges et lycées dans les
autres départements
l'ensemble des mesures déjà en vigueur
reste inchangé quelques heures avant
l'annoncé du premier ministre c'est le
président en personne qui se déplaçaient
dans un ehpad du xiiie arrondissement de
la capitale
emmanuel macron a tenu à rappeler la
volonté du gouvernement de protéger les
plus fragiles
nous sommes vous le savez encore dans ce
qu'on appelle cette phase 2 en train
d'essayer de ralentir l'épidémie de
covile 19 nous passerons
dans sans doute les prochains jours dans
une nouvelle phase quand l'ensemble des
régions est que le virus sera plus
largement répandus où il faudra
continuer de lutter contre ce virus en
protégeant les personnes qui sont les
plus fragiles et c'est aujourd'hui cela
notre priorité
initialement prévue jusqu'au 31 mai
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de cinq mille personnes en milieu
clos a été ramené à mi-avril dernière
annulation en date le salon du tatouage
qui devaient avoir lieu du 13 au 15 mars
à paris
[Musique]